welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for our presentation titled
verifying
immuno-oncology related gene expression
patterns in colon tumor samples
using rfid tagged tachman panels
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
steve jackson
a senior research and development
scientist in the genetic
science division here at thermo fisher
scientific
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today
for a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
we encourage you to submit your
questions in the q a box
our speaker will address questions
following his
presentation please join me now in
welcoming dr
jackson i will now turn the presentation
over
to him welcome dr jackson
hello my name is steve jackson i'm the
associate director of product
applications here at thermo fisher
scientific
and in this in this talk i'm going to
talk to you a little bit about
how you can analyze any oncology related
gene expression patterns
using tumor research samples using rfid
tagged attackman panels
and this exploits our new flagship
quantstudio 67 pro
instrument that has a lot of smart
features which i'll briefly touch on
as a result of these of this talk
so one of the main problems that we're
facing um when when dealing with cancer
is that a tumor sample can be sensitive
to uh
growth deactivation using a number of
immune system checkpoints
um there are several different these of
the checkpoint pathways that exist
there's the the ctla4
there's pdl1 there's there's uh there's
a lot of different uh
i won't say a lot but there's several
different checkpoint pathways
um but but many times you you are unsure
which of those pathways are going to
work to to inhibit cell growth
um so how can you tell which one is
effective um
one of the ways you can analyze this is
by looking at expression of subsets of
genes and tumor sample
and ex by looking at the subsets of
these genes you might be able to say
um which of these pathways might be
effective in inhibiting
growth of these these tumor cells
thus there's a way to there's a need to
easily analyze gene expression levels in
immune oncology
research subjects research pathways
so um over the course of this talk i'll
basically make use of an experiment we
did
where we obtained 10 uh colon tumor
and adjacent normal adjacent ffpe
samples
we analyzed expression levels of these
genes by looking at two uh gene
expression signatures that were defined
in publications that came out recently
these
expression signatures are associated
with with immuno immuno oncological
response
and then we correlated differences in
expression signatures of these two
groups of genes um in three different
comparisons
we look at tumor versus normal with
pdl-1 positive staining versus negative
staining
and we looked at microsatellite stable
versus microsatellite unstable
groups of these of these colon tumor
samples
so as i mentioned we recently came out
with a quant studio 67 pro
real time system this is our flagship uh
quan
real time pcr system and um we have
introduced
several new features that make this uh
easier
easier for you to use in laboratory one
of them is that it has facial
recognition and voice commands um so
you can respond to your face or our
voice commands
freeing up your hands for doing uh other
things
it introduces rfid plate readers
so that on an rfid tag there are certain
things that can be coded and
automatically uploaded into the
instrument we'll have more to say about
that in a second
it's a true standalone operation with no
external computer needed
it facilitates tech support by having a
direct
contact with tech support and readily
downloadable
files by tech support team to to help
speed resolution of
technical problems and there are other
things you can read here
block ease of changing um
cloud connectivity um instrument connect
monitoring all these things
help make this instrument very easy to
use
and and take your pcr experiments to the
next level
now as i mentioned the quant studio 67
pro comes with rfid
tagging this is a radio frequency tag
that is embedded into a plate
where the the the rfid
enables the smart workflow smart
workflow
the rfid can it can include the plate
layout
all the assay information and run method
all in this rfid tag
it could be to get immediately
transferred to the eds file
um after the run is completed and and um
when you're running started it will be
uploaded to the instrument so you just
have to basically
put it in and and and turn it on and go
attackman assays in these rfid tech
plates are pre-spotted on the plate
and so it's very convenient then you
just add your sample and master mix and
you're off to the races
and then finally um the data analysis is
very easy because you don't have to
download tacman files and upload
a plate layout once the experiment is
complete the data is immediately
analyzable because the eds file
contains all the important information
about the uh the
location of the assays and the run that
was done
so um it's the most simplified workflow
as shown here on the left hand side of
this
this slide so
um what we did was that we used these
two publications to
to uh order rfid tagged plates
that had these two signatures embedded
in them
one of the signatures was based on an
heirs at all publication that came out
in jay
journal clinical investigation 2017.
this this is a t cell and flame gene
expression signature that predicted
response to pd1 inhibitors
again you can go back to the original
publication to find out what these genes
actually were but
um this is one subset of the genes that
we that we put into the
into the um into the plate
another publication came out of the
group uh shikhala at
um at all shikha shukla at all
this was published in cell last or in
2018
um in this in this publication they
looked at
a set of germline antigen genes that
particular resistance
that predict resistance to ctl for
responsiveness
so eight different genes that that were
um were um
indicative of how well the the ctla4 was
going to be able to work in those cells
uh we also had um uh housekeeping genes
um that were that
eight different housekeeping genes
included in the reference plate and so
we
uh ordered these rfid tagged plates that
had both the pdl1
i'm sorry the pd1 inhibitors and the
ctla inhibitors
embedded in them we then analyzed those
those
10 on uh tumor and adjacent normal genes
colon tumor samples um
and look at the differences in
expression patterns that we were able to
see
so at first on uh in the t cell and
flame gene expression uh set
um when we looked at tumor versus normal
uh we saw that there's a significant
difference in the t
cell inflamed gene signature in the
tumor samples compared to the normal
samples
that we found by by doing some uh uh
statistical analysis of these the
difference is statistically significant
with a p level point zero two here you
can see that the
um the the overall uh uh signature of
the genes
not every gene but this signature in
general was was
was upregulated by reflecting
its lower ct score these genes were
upregulated in the tumor cells versus
the normal cells
so no real surprise there we would
expect there to be some of the tumor
genes that would be responsive
to to pdl one
if we made the same comparison looking
at the crma genes uh
um the crma is par uh what the others uh
subset
of gene expression the other subset of
genes we were looking at the gene
expression of
in that um in that taqman plate we found
there is no statistically different
expression
of the crma genes when we just look at
tumor versus normal research
samples so here we did not see that
there was a difference in
in and in the comparison of just looking
at normal versus tumor
now when we we wanted to look at
the the pdl ones positive
tumor cells and see if we can see
differences in expression
um if if we now uh grade them or or
differentiate them based on cdl i'm
sorry
pdl1 staining versus no staining and so
we sent the samples off to a third party
to to get
uh staining here we can see an h a um
hematoxylin eosin staining of a normal
colon
antipedial one standing of this of an
adjacent section and no
antibody of an adjacent section here and
this is this is from the the tumor
um that was uh adjacent to the normal
tissue um
here we see the h e staining there's uh
pdl1 staining throughout this particular
sample
and again that's specific to the
antibody because no antibody didn't show
any staining at all
so now if we if we look at the pdl one
positive versus
vl1 negative staining we can see that
the t cell signature is significantly
higher in the pdl-1 stain samples versus
versus pdl-1 positive versus pl1
negative samples
but again when we look at focusing on
the crma subset of the genes we don't
see a difference
in in crma gene expression
when we look at pdl one when we compare
pl1 positive to pdl1 negative stained
samples again not a terrible surprise
since
we expect that there'd be some t-cell
infiltration um causing the upregulation
of of the t-cell um ex
inflammation specific genes
the last thing i'm going to i'm going to
talk about is the um the
micro satellite status of these samples
for this we turned to our true mark
microsatellite instability assay
this is an assay released last year that
is
a way to look at 13 different
microsatellite markers
it makes use of as little as two
nanograms of ffpe derived dna
and we have facilitated the analysis of
msi stable and unstable with with
customized
software and one particular aspect of
the software is that we
don't require there to be a matched
normal sample
for the analysis we make use of an
extensive database of normal samples to
to
come up with the normal samples that our
software uses now again in this case
here we did have normal samples that we
that were able to compare to
uh and to make the micro satellite calls
and we did that um for for the
experience i'll tell you about here
overall you can extract dna uh and get
an answer as little as four hours
um with less than one hour hands-on time
and this runs on the seek studio and
other 3 500
genetic analyzers so it's a ce based
micro satellite instability assay
and so we use this assay then to to
differentiate a microsatellite stable
for microsoft like unstable
tumor samples here and when we look at
the msi
uh we look at the the t
cell inflammation gene expression
signature
um in microsatellite high versus
microsatellite stable
samples we don't see a difference in
expression
of that particular signature but when we
look at the signature of the crma
genes we do see that there's a
difference in the micro satellite
unstable samples
we see that there's a lower expression
of the crma genes whereas in the
microsatellite stable
tumors that there is an upregulation of
this set of crma genes
this suggests that in the tumor cells
that are microsatellite stable
they might be resistant to blockage
using ctla
antagonists whereas the the
microsatellite high
samples might might be affected
by ctla blockage so this is this might
be a way then to
to distinguish between the way that the
uh
um the cells these cells might respond
to a
uh immy oncology
blocker
so this talk we talked about ways you
can use attackman
gene expression panel to differentiate
the way that the tumor samples might be
able to respond to an immune oncology
treatment
in these experiments we had use of some
of the smart features of the quantum
studio 67 pro and our
rfid tagged plates that really helped
facilitate the speed at which this work
was done because we didn't have to mess
with
uploading tacman sam attackman assay
identifications and mapping them to a
plate etc that was all done on the rfid
tag
these rfid tag plates can be custom
ordered from us
and they'll be pre-spotted with with any
taqman assay
um i showed you that gene expression
signature discovery analysis can be an
important part of human oncology
research program
and panels that contain tagline assays
for sets of genes
can define a signature um and can be
used for these immunocollageal
immunolog oncological uh research
results
i want to emphasize these uh these um
these panels and everything here is for
research use only
and not for uh in diagnostic use
finally i want to to acknowledge harita
beerus lingam a member of my team who
did
all of the work here and comey of arma
on whose
watch this work was performed and thank
you very much for your time
thank you dr jackson for that
outstanding presentation
and we will now move into the live q a
portion
of the presentation as a reminder to our
audience members please submit your
questions
in the q a box so let's take a look at
the questions already coming in
[Music]
dr jackson are there existing rfid
tagged
tackman panels uh right now there aren't
right now all the rfid tagged uh tagman
panels have to be made custom
it's fairly easy to do but we don't have
any off-the-shelf rfid tech
panels yet we hope to be able to have
these uh
in the future but for right now
everything is custom
thank you so much our next audience
member wants to know why use tacman
assays to analyze gene expression
differences
wouldn't sequencing be more appropriate
that's that's a really good question
when we get asked a lot
so sequencing next-gen sequencing as we
know is a fantastic tool that really
pushed
the boundaries of what we know about
several different things um
and and it tends to make a very
extensive queries um
it makes very uh a detailed analysis
um a very very deep um
data generation that is often kind of
time
often difficult to analyze sometimes you
often are overwhelmed the amount of data
that is generated and it takes uh you
know often a team of bioinformatics
experts to go through the data um it's
it's just a very complicated
uh workflow so while next gen sequencing
is
is extremely useful for generating uh
unbiased
um data queries for for doing discovery
based research
many times once you have identified a
set of genes you want to focus in on uh
you don't need the power of next-gen
sequencing
and this is where taqman comes into play
is because taqman um will
will give you a very uh um
uh uh accurate uh very easy
um to generate results um without the
detail and the uh and the
expense often this you need to do a
whole next-gen sequencing experiment
so tacman assays are are when you want
to focus
in on a set of genes it's a more
appropriate way to go the next-gen
sequencing because you don't need to
have all that information
thank you so much i want to thank our
audience for these great questions
and remind them that any questions we
don't answer today
will be answered via email
dr jackson we have time for one more
question why did you include
msi analysis in these samples
so we want to do that because you know
um
many times when a tumor becomes micro
satellite unstable
um it winds up generating things called
neo antigens these are these are novel
uh protein epitopes that are that are
made in tumor cells
that can be exploited by the immune
system to attack the tumor
and and hopefully use your own immune
system to to
um to attack it and and um
by by using these these uh um
immune system um um
um gate blockers that the pdl1
inhibitors the ctla inhibitors the
things that that block
the down down regulation of the immune
response you can often
uh enhance the ability of the immune
system to then take care of these these
tumors
and so we include msi analysis in here
as sort of a
a way to analyze the the immunogenic
potential
by having these new antigens be produced
we didn't look at
neuroantigens per se here but we use the
msi as a surrogate for analyzing that
the neo energetic potential
that's present in these cells
thank you so much dr jackson and i want
to thank you for your presentation today
and for your time and i also want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and again
remind you that any questions not
answered today will be answered
via email i also want to remind you to
not miss out on the other valuable
presentations during this
virtual event visit the agenda tab
in the auditorium for a full listing of
the presentations
and to learn more about the solutions
mentioned in this presentation
please visit the qpcr and the sanger
sequencing booths
in the exhibit hall or you can just
click on the red
request more information button on the
screens throughout this virtual event
lastly this presentation will be
available on demand
viewing through september 30th 2021
please share that with a colleague who
may have missed today's live event
thank you again for participation thank
you dr jackson
this session is over take care and stay
healthy
bye bye everyone